bien dormir c'est important
voilà
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite oui enfin bon bien
dormir c'est important vous le savez
maintenant si vous êtes des habitués vu
que j'ai fait quand même pas mal de
vidéos sur le sujet mais il nous restait
quand même un petit truc à voir ensemble
et ben on va en parler tout de suite je
vais me changer
[Musique]
la qualité de notre sommeil elle est
importante au niveau physique et aussi
au niveau psychologique parce que ça
joue aussi sur notre santé mentale on
avait déjà fait le tour des conseils
pour mieux dormir je vous invite à
retourner voir la vidéo si vous avez
oublié vous allez voir c'est pas des
trucs très très compliqué à faire et il
nous manquait un sujet à voir ensemble
mais avant de vous en parler j'ai
quelque chose à vous dire cette vidéo
est sponsorisée par Emma Emma c'est un
site sur lequel vous allez pouvoir
trouver tout ce qui vous faut pour
chouchouter votre sommeil ils ont déjà
sponsorisé plusieurs de mes vidéos sur
le sujet et à chaque fois je teste leurs
produits j'ai déjà les oreillers à
mémoire de forme le surmatelas à mémoire
de forme la couette le linge de lit etc
etc cette fois je passe au matelas et
pas n'importe lequel le matelas hybride
premium autant vous dire le haut du
panier mémoire de forme pour épouser les
contours de mon corps matière respirante
pour rester frais je parle du bacharge
je l'ai commandé il est arrivé 72 heures
plus tard dans ce sympathique carton
très facile à ouvrir et je l'ai testé et
après j'ai testé le matelas c'était
beaucoup beaucoup mieux je sens bien que
vous êtes jaloux attendez bougez pas
j'arrive avant de vous donner mon code
promo il faut que je vous dise un ou
deux trucs sur Emma déjà vous avez vu la
livraison elle est rapide elle est
pratique mais elle est aussi gratuite et
le retour aussi si jamais oui parce que
vous avez s'ennuie pour tester le
produit que vous avez reçu et pour le
renvoyer si vous convient pas le matelas
hybride il a été 7 fois primé en Europe
et le Emma original ça a été le plus
vendu en France pendant 2 ans de suite
et tout ça c'est garanti 10 ans après si
vous prévoyez pas de changer forcément
de matelas tout de suite je vous ai dit
il y a plein d'autres accessoires sur
leur site allez jeter un œil vous allez
trouver votre bonheur et donc comme
promis avec le code promo corps vous
avez 10% de réduction sur le site en
plus des réductions qui a déjà oui parce
que en ce moment c'est les soldes d'été
ce code il est valable jusqu'au 25
juillet à minuit donc allez faire un
tour sur le site d'Emma que je vous ai
mis dans la description de la vidéo et
hop donc on avait vu les trucs à faire
pour bien dormir mais on n'avait pas
encore parlé de la meilleure position
pour dormir on va faire le tour de
toutes les possibilités et on va voir
quelle est la meilleure et lesquelles
sont les pires allez on commence tout de
suite avec dormir sur le côté ça c'est
la position la plus courante à priori la
moitié d'entre vous qui est en train de
regarder cette vidéo dort sur le côté
mais est-ce que c'est la meilleure
position bah à vrai dire ça dépend elle
a des avantages mais elle a quand même
pas mal d'inconvénients aussi dormir en
position fœtale comme un fœtus pas en
position fécale ça c'est autre chose
après donc vous faites comme vous voulez
c'est vous qui l'avez les draps dormir
en position fœtale ou en chien de fusil
c'est à peu près la même chose ou
quelque soit la position mais sur le
côté c'est pas forcément l'idéal pour
les articulations c'est pas génial au
niveau des épaules par exemple c'est pas
génial au niveau du dos voir pas
forcément au niveau des jambes non plus
à moins de bien se caler partout avec
des oreillers pour bien tout avoir dans
l'axe mais bon après si vous bougez un
petit peu c'est foutu
et puis suivant le côté sur lequel vous
dormez ça peut faire peser le poids de
votre corps sur différents organes les
organes digestifs par exemple avec des
répercussions à ce niveau là et puis il
y a aussi ce truc que vous connaissez
sûrement si vous vous endormez sur votre
bras vous risquez de vous réveiller avec
le bras tout mort et ça c'est pas très
agréable
d'ailleurs spontanément dans ces cas là
on se dit que si on a le bras tout
engourdi au réveil c'est parce qu'en
dormant dessus on a coupé la circulation
sanguine c'est pas faux mais c'est pas
la seule raison c'est surtout parce que
quand tout notre poids repose comme ça
sur notre bras ça comprime les nerfs qui
sont à l'intérieur et quand ils sont
compris mais ils arrêtent de fonctionner
correctement nos nerfs il faut savoir
qu'ils ont essentiellement deux
fonctions il s'occupe de la sensibilité
c'est à dire qu'il donne les sensations
le toucher etc et il s'occupe aussi de
la motricité c'est à dire que c'est eux
qui envoient des impulsions électriques
à nos muscles pour les faire fonctionner
et donc quand on honneur sont comprimés
ils aiment pas trop ça du coup ils se
mettent en grève si vous voulez ils
arrêtent d'envoyer leurs informations du
coup non seulement on sent plus rien
mais en plus on peut plus bouger alors
bon c'est pas dangereux mais si on a le
sommeil très lourd et qu'on reste
vraiment très longtemps endormi sur son
bras le réveil est pas génial après au
niveau positif dormir sur le côté c'est
la meilleure position en cas de
grossesse oui parce que déjà bon bah sur
le ventre passer un certain stade c'est
même plus la peine d'y penser et sur le
dos ça peut être ça peut être pesant ça
peut être écrasant et ça peut compliquer
aussi la circulation sanguine c'est
aussi une bonne position à adopter si on
ronfle parce que ça a tendance à
atténuer le problème
[Musique]
petit truc à pas négliger dormir sur le
côté c'est aussi la possibilité de
dormir en cuillère si on dort pas seul
bon ça c'est soit la meilleure chose
soit la pire chose c'est un peu une
question de goût moi j'aime bien
bref sur le côté il y a du pour et du
contre ça dépend un peu de votre
situation mais alors dormir sur le
ventre bon là encore évidemment ça
dépend de vos spécificités physiques
mais globalement c'est quand même la
position qui a le pire rapport positif
négatif déjà au niveau des postures ça
respecte pas du tout les courbures du
dos c'est différent selon qu'on est du
ventre et de la poitrine ou pas du tout
selon que notre matelas soit mou ou pas
du tout mais globalement pour la colonne
vertébrale c'est pas génial il y a même
un spécialiste de la posture du sommeil
qui dit que c'est la pire position
avec une petite mention spéciale pour
les cervicales qui sont vraiment
complètement tordus parce que on a la
tête complètement sur le côté à moins
d'avoir la tête complètement dans
l'oreiller mais là on meurt c'est pas
très bon pour la santé enfin plus
sérieusement quand on est le ventre la
cage thoracique se développe pas tout à
fait correctement donc en plus on
respire moins bien comme notre poids
repose sur notre ventre donc sur notre
estomac pour les histoires de digestion
et pour les problèmes de remontée acide
c'est pas génial non plus en plus on
dort la bouche ouverte là on bave sur
l'oreiller c'est dégueulasse ça pue donc
bon et pourtant c'est la deuxième
position la plus fréquente après dormir
sur le côté ce qui nous laisse donc la
moins courante c'est-à-dire dormir sur
le dos bon c'est la position la plus mal
aimée et si on regarde comme ça vite
fait bah on peut se dire que c'est bien
mérité dormir sur le dos ça favorise les
ronflements et l'apnée du sommeil dont
on avait déjà parlé ici avec Ben de Nota
Bene ça favorise aussi le bruxisme
c'est-à-dire le fait de grincer des
dents on en avait parlé aussi mais d'un
autre côté au niveau du dos c'est quand
même beaucoup mieux c'est la meilleure
des trois tout est bien aligné tout est
bien rectiligne et si votre matelas est
pas trop défoncé la colonne vertébrale
elle est aussi dans une courbure idéale
c'est à dire que ça évite les tensions
les douleurs etc au niveau des autres
articulations c'est pareil on est dans
une position qui est neutre qui est
assez naturelle donc on est bien pas de
remontée acide non plus ou le problème
digestifs c'est quand même dommage que
cette histoire de respiration sinon on
est parfait quoi ah oui parce que quand
on est allongé sur le dos à plat comme
ça toutes les parties molles tous les
tissus mous qu'on a dans le fond de la
gorge ça vient se plaquer contre
l'entrée de la trachée donc non
seulement on respire pas bien mais en
plus ça vibre ça fait du bruit etc vous
connaissez heureusement on a trouvé la
solution la NASA vient de trouver la
solution
la NASA oui oui la NASA alors je veux
pas vous mentir il cherchait pas
vraiment une solution pour qu'on puisse
dormir sur le dos sans ronfler donc il
cherchait la position idéale pour les
astronautes pour qu'ils dorment le mieux
possible pour qu'il récupère bien qu'il
respire correctement et qui soit en
pleine forme pour faire leur truc de
d'astronautes là cette position ils
l'ont appelé la position zéro gravité et
c'est celle là donc sur le dos
évidemment avec le torse et la tête un
petit peu surélevée pour éviter ces
problèmes de respiration dont on vient
de parler parce que quand on est assis
bah tout ça ça tombe pas dans le fond
donc pas de problème et puis les jambes
un petit peu surélevé aussi comme ça non
seulement il y a pas de tension
musculaire articulaire etc mais en plus
la circulation se fait parfaitement bien
bon après c'est un peu technique comme
position en gros vous avez deux options
soit vous achetez un lit électrique
ajustable c'est un petit budget quand
même je vous cache pas soit vous
bricolez un truc maison après si vous
n'êtes pas super manuel vous pouvez
aussi vous débrouiller avec des oreilles
mais là c'est toujours le même problème
quoi faut pas trop bouger parce que
sinon ah oui sinon troisième possibilité
faut être astronaute merci la NASA bon
en réalité vous avez compris il y a pas
vraiment une position idéale qui marche
pour tout le monde ça dépend de pas mal
de paramètres qui peuvent varier
beaucoup d'une personne à l'autre notre
morphologie la forme de notre corps si
vous voulez nos petites particularités
nos maladies éventuellement notre type
de sommeil est-ce qu'il est léger est-ce
qu'il est profond est-ce qu'on arrive à
changer un petit peu de position quand
il y a un truc qui nous gêne donc bref
se rapprocher de la position idéale de
la NASA ok c'est cool pourquoi pas mais
le truc important c'est surtout bah tout
bêtement de trouver la position dans
laquelle on dort le mieux parce que la
qualité du sommeil ça compte aussi se
mettre parfaitement dans la position des
astronautes mais pas réussir à fermer
l'oeil de la nuit à cause de ça c'est
pas super rentable en termes de qualité
de vie on est d'accord donc par exemple
si vous alternez un peu sur le côté un
peu sur le dos etc c'est déjà pas mal et
puis de toute façon c'est pas vraiment
comme si vous choisissiez vous dormez
voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous bien
[Musique]